the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thursday and
house of the dragon update video in this
video we will be looking at another new
article that reveals some more
interesting information regarding hbo's
new game of thrones series house of the
dragon in this new article we learn
about when a song of ice and fire author
george rr martin went to house of the
dragon showrunners ryan condell and
miguel sapochnick and told them he
wanted to see three very specific things
added to their new show these were three
things that former game of thrones
writers david and dan left out of the
main series
now before we actually get into the
video i want to take a moment to discuss
the sponsor of this video atlas vpn as
i'm sure most of you already know all of
us are at risk of having our identity
stolen on a daily basis as more and more
of our information and data goes onto
the internet what some of you might not
know is that one of the best ways to
stop this from happening is by the use
of a vpn service
now this is something that i've actually
been using every day for the last 6
months
well this month i've joined forces with
atlas vpn to bring you the most
affordable deal on online protection for
as little as
and 83 cents a month not to mention they
also have a 30 day money back guarantee
now on top of guarding your online
identity atlas vpn also blocks malware
and malicious links it keeps your google
searches private and even gives you
access to online shopping deals and will
even notify you whenever someone is
trying to steal your identity another
one of my favorite things about this is
it also gives you access to other
regions content on the different
streaming services like netflix for
example if something is only available
in the uk all you have to do is switch
your ip address to be able to gain
access to it in the us
right now atlas vpn is running a massive
discount to where you can actually get a
three year subscription for only one
dollar and 83 cents each month and like
i said that has a 30-day money-back
guarantee as well you can actually jump
on that deal right now before time runs
out by going to the link in my
description i would recommend grabbing
that deal now i want to thank atlasvpn
for sponsoring this video now let's see
what the article actually says
as hbo embarked on a brand new
adaptation of george rr martin's novels
this time of fire and blood instead of
the song of ice and fire the fantasy
author made a few key requests of the
new showrunners during an event attended
by insider house of the dragon coast
showrunners miguel sapochnick and ryan
condell said there were three things
that martin has to have included they
said he wanted the dragons to be
colorful and an emphasis on bright
heraldry and the addition of king
jiharis targaryen the second of his name
now some of you might be wondering why
is this great news what difference does
it really make we already knew about
these new additions to the dragons
because we have seen them ourselves and
all the official photos and videos hbo
has been releasing
well i think this is great news because
it's another example of george rr
martin's involvement with house of the
dragon this shows that they are actually
respecting him by not only listening to
what he has to say but giving him what
he wants as well
this is actually very different to how
he was handled during the run of game of
thrones we know that now because he
already wanted these additions in game
of thrones but he never got them until
now i think this is great because it
shows how him and these new showrunners
have a healthy relationship maybe it's
only me who believes this but i think
this is a really great sign moving
forward i hope this is a small glimpse
of what will come in the future it
starts with him getting this small
addition added to the show but hopefully
it will lead to him getting even bigger
things added into the show down the road
we shall see now according to house of
the dragon showrunner miguel sapochnick
george r martin made note of when game
of thrones showrunners david benioff and
d.b weiss left jaehaerys out of the
listed line of rulers when it came to
historical targaryen kings and the
fictional universe david and dan skipped
over jaehaerys for reasons of clarity
that he really did not understand
sapochnick said when referring to author
george rr martin he had to be in his
bonnet about it he wanted us to write
that wrong
so it sounds like this made george r
martin upset or at the very least annoy
that they decided to leave this out of
game of thrones
as for the other additions he wanted
that revolved around color george r
martin was hopeful that house of the
dragon would be the perfect time for
fans to see dragons of varying size
shape and color in game of thrones
daenerys targaryen's three dragons had
distinct coloring drogon named for call
drogo had black and red scales viserion
named for her brother viserys was golden
and rhaegal named for her other brother
rhaegar was green and bronze however as
her dragons got larger their coloring
became a subtle accent among dark black
and grey scales in house of the dragon
however each dragon should be distinct
enough for the fans to know which
targaryen is flying on them based simply
on the color of the dragon scales it
definitely seems like this is something
they have addressed in house of the
dragon we have seen several dragons
already and so far each of them do look
very different from one another this was
a great addition if you ask me it's
something that i think was necessary
especially when there will be so many
more dragons in this game of thrones
series now george r martin also asked
that house of the dragon add a lot of
symbolic color related to all the major
and minor houses of westeros he spoke
with ryan condo about the heraldry fans
who would want to see this and how these
minor additions will have significance
in the show it's such a time of high
decadence and wealth and prosperity for
the realm ryan condell said everybody
would really adorn themselves in their
house colors and be proud of them as
they marched into the tournament now all
we have to do is wait a little over a
week before we're finally able to see
all of these new additions get brought
to life in the new game of thrones
successor show house of the dragon
thanks to george rr martin we will
finally see how different each of the
dragons should actually look i don't
know about all of you but that's the
newest addition i'm looking forward to
the most from what i've seen so far in
all of the new videos and photos hbo has
been releasing it already looks like
they've done an amazing job at making
each of the dragons stand out from one
another let me know which one you like
the most out of the three things george
rr martin wanted added into the show
the targaryens are the sort of
fascinating dynasty that we don't really
know much about from the original books
because at that point they've all died
out
game of thrones
begins
roughly 298 ac
almost 300 years after
aegon's conquest
household dragon
takes place a couple hundred years
before game of thrones
the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
birthright
before the war house targaryen counted
18 dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens
he would never be as powerful or as
feared again leave me your thoughts down
below as always i want to thank everyone
for stopping by and watching the video i
also want to thank atlas vpn again for
sponsoring the video as well i hope all
of you have a great day i will see you
again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you